على المستويين السياسي والشعبي لم ينتظر
الفلسطينيون طويلا لاعلان موقفهم من
تشكيله الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده
الرئيس محمود عباس كان قد استبق تشكيلها
بالقول انه يعرف نتنياهو منذ التسعينيات
وكان قد تعامل معه مضيفا بانه لا يؤمن
بالسلام
الحكومه التي صادق عليها الكنيست
الاسرائيلي باغلبيه تقول حركه حماس ان لها
سياسات تصعيديه
من الواضح اننا سنكون اليوم امام حكومه
صهيونيه جديده هي الاكثر التطرفا وارهابا
وعنصريه وفاشيه ولديها سياسات واضحه في
الصعيد العدوان ضد مقدساتنا ضد الشعبنا
وارضنا كما يحذر قيادي في حماس من تجاوز
اسرائيل لما يصفها بالخطوط الحمراء لان
ذلك من شانه ان يقود الى انفجار على حد
تعبيره الرد الفلسطيني الشعبي لم يختلف
كثيرا عن ما جاء على لسان الطبقه السياسيه
على الشعب الفلسطيني في ظل الحكومه
على قلب رجل واحد كل الحكومات المتعاقبه
الاسرائيليه فشلت همم الاضداد على حقوق
الشعب الفلسطيني
الصهيونيه الدينيه والقوه اليهوديه
القومتين المتشددين والذين اظهره جانبا من
سياساتهما خلال محادثات تشكيله الحكومه
قادات داخليه وخارجيه على السواء
[تصفيق]